about whether California should secede
from their union
we joining us now via Skype we hope the
connection is solid is marcos ruiz evans
the president of yes california a group
advocating for the Golden State's
independence from America I'll pause it
the same question to you that I did last
time Marcus so unhappy with sanctuary
state unhappy with standard of living up
unhappy with even telling us the coffee
is bad for us whatever your grievance is
a lot of people especially conservatives
independents frustrated with the status
of California is the option at this
point to say we want out yeah I think it
is for California as for Americans
Reuters did a poll in January 2017 and
it showed 47 points five forty seven
point five percent of Californians were
quote not opposed having a discussion
about the session 32% were forward but a
larger percent said let's do it
let's talk about this and then when you
look at Rasmussen did a poll in February
2017 forty-one percent of Republicans
that go ahead and take off won't bother
us in the slightest thirty two percent
of Americans that they again don't let
the door hit you on the way out so now
those polls were taken before the
sanctuary battle they were taken before
sessions in flew to California and said
you can't deceive before all of this
hoopla we have almost half of
Californians open to the idea of talking
about secession forty-one percent of
Republicans who control the federal
government this time and one-third of
Americans in general saying I'm open to
this and that's before the difficulties
now Marcus says this we do that again
it's just a reflection that you believe
America and California have
irreconcilable differences that
ultimately the priorities are so
different that a divorce is necessary at
this point yes I mean obviously whenever
you talk to anybody they're gonna say
it's very clear that California and
America are in a war of battle there's
this constant legislative battling with
each other I agree with Jeff sessions on
this one point very specifically this is
not a stable way to govern
constant battling lawsuits challenges in
court the inability to actually execute
policies saying anything you do I'm
gonna do the opposite that is highly
unstable you can't eat government you
can't run a United States of America a
republic when an entire state is
flaunting federal law and saying we're
not going to follow it at some point
that all breaks down now I understand
the argument that you're making what is
the path to something like this at
briefly the path to something like this
actually happening well it's very simple
a lot of people think that calyx is
crazy simply because they don't know the
laws here in California we can final an
initiative on a wide variety of things
in fact we filed initiatives saying we
want to put a vote in front of
Californians ask if they want to leave
America a couple times it's been
approved by multiple California
attorneys general so we can have
Californians Dinka votans de dieu
majority want to leave America the next
thing is you have to go to Congress and
ask for permission to leave a lot of
people think you can't secede that is
ignorance Exodus vs. white is a Supreme
Court case after the Civil War after the
Civil War that said if you get consent
of the states you can leave and finally
we think that America will let us go I
mean well it's Fox News watch TV see how
conservatives are talk at the same time
it's it's a it's it's the sixth largest
economy in the world as well and while
there might be massive differences that
would be one heck of a ballot showdown I
know there's likely a ballot showdown in
2020 as well about California being a
sanctuary state this would take it to a
whole another level
Marcus Ruiz Evans making the case for
Cal exit
we will follow how America and the
relationship with California continues
appreciate your time tonight
thank you